reese witherspoon welcome to Fandango
frontrunners I am very happy to have you
here it's my favorite thing to go to
movies on Monday oh really
you've got the whole theater to yourself
let's see if yellow and orange go
together this is your chair can't see
Reese it's really great to see you today
good to see you thank you for joining me
you know this is such an exciting time
in your career you have your second
Oscar nomination for a wild you know how
much I love this movie we've talked
about it and I you're so great when you
think back to earlier in your life
earlier in your career is there a moment
or an experience that really sticks out
as a pivotal moment for you first of all
the first movie I ever got was such a
interesting experience because I went in
to be an extra basically I read an ad in
the paper I was living in Nashville
Tennessee and his man the moon man in
the moon and you know I went in an
audition and I didn't hear anything for
a month and then you know that I heard
from the director was the director of To
Kill a Mockingbird and I had to come to
LA and never been to Los Angeles or the
West Coast and I did a screen test and
then about a month later I got the part
and it was kind of amazing
too because I have no formal training
really but that director Robert Mulligan
really spent time with me and he was
just an incredibly patient man and I
will always be appreciative for the time
he took with me but talk about jumping
right into the deep end I mean a lot of
people as teen actors worked their way
up they'll start with a bit part or
something and you had your first role as
the lead role of the movie that must
have been so scary well I can't I didn't
understand really that it was such a big
deal so that I had that in my advantage
um my second audition ever was was for
Cape Fear with Martin Scorsese cuz the
DP had shot man and moon and he
suggested me for the part so mr.
Scorsese flew me up to New York and I
was supposed to read with the lead actor
but I didn't know who that was so I was
sitting on the plane and this man a
businessman turns to me and I was 14
years old in a Laura Ashley dress he
goes what are you what are you doing
little girl like where are you going I
said well I'm going to New York to
audition for a movie and he said Oh
who's in the movie I said somebody named
Robert De Niro
no I hate the man like literally was
like are you kidding me is it the
greatest American actor of all time
I had no idea who he was Wow no clue who
Martin Scorsese was nothing he doesn't
say I bricked the audition right hi
Juliette Lewis welcome to the role of a
lifetime I literally did not stop
shaking until I walked out of the room
Wow
Robert dude never had to finish all my
lines because I literally would like
couldn't save a line but it was a great
experience you know and and I remember
Robert De Niro being so kind because
then I found like seven years later I
auditioned for another one of his movie
seems like I remember you like you've
gotten better all right speaking of
getting better I want to take a look at
what probably is my favorite scene from
my favorite movie of 2014 and this is a
scene of you near the end of the movie
wild where your character Cheryl Strayed
has finished this huge hike and she
encounters a really interesting pair of
people near the end of her journey so
take this remote we're gonna watch the
scene together and pause it and talk
about it here's you in wild I'm vera and
this is Kyle I'm Cheryl are you enjoying
your hike today loving a wonderful time
thank you very much faster you're so
polite okay we have to start by talking
about this little boy he's amazing ever
no to lose his marital I yes and he was
super committed to this wasn't he yes he
came in so prepared and so polite and so
um just by the book it was so
interesting cuz I thought oh he's being
very you know polite and a little like
formal and then I went back and looked
at the book and it said I met the most
polite formal little boy and we had a
very stilted conversation and then he
said to me can I sing you a song so the
kid had read the book I mean it was
crazy how much he understood what that
was and he's so little that's great that
he was so prepared
I will it continues we just thought with
really weekend rain or no hmm where is
my grandmom just something afternoon
because I have some problems I'm not
supposed to talk a lot of strangers
I love that look on your face it's this
kind of surprise and is this an okay
conversation to be having and what
should I do
right right yeah I think you know Cheryl
immediately senses in him that there's
something that she sees in herself
mmm all right let's see what happens
well you don't have to talk about them
but you know everybody has problems I
have problems too what I noticed when I
watch the scene is the peace with which
you speak as Cheryl I think because
she's gone through this journey and
there has been a lot of anger but she's
coming out the other side is that where
you see it for sure I think you know
this is Cheryl sort of maturing and as
we get to the end of the movie we start
to see in the script and in the story
that she has become the Cheryl that I
know now which is a person who can
reflect on the experience and see it not
just as the negative but that there are
so many beautiful blessings in having
you know interruptions in your life or
great pain in your life doesn't always
have to be a negative thing gonna be
this this learning experience yeah let's
keep watching what kinds of problems
well I mean I've problems my dad I don't
see him anymore either mommy she died I
mean you just have to be so gentle when
you're imparting news like that to a
little child even if it's someone the
child doesn't know yeah but there's
something so clear about a child you
know it's interesting she goes on this
whole journey no one really asked her
specifically what happened this is the
first person that's asked her exactly
what happened and did you and Cheryl
talk about this moment because she was
on set a lot yeah this moment was
preceded by a we didn't put it in the
movie but it was a rant about how mad
she is at her mother it comes out of a
great moment of anger at her mother how
dare you leave me how dare I didn't get
to be a petulant teenager and yell at
you and then grow up and
and realized the error of my ways and
apologized so she actually feels very
robbed before she sees him okay here we
go
but you know problems don't stay
problems they turn into something else
she got very sick this is where you
start to feel even more of the emotional
weight of this did you film this near
the end of the process were you able to
shoot in some kind of order yeah this
was towards the end and Sheryl was there
this day and I knew I remember being
really nervous that I was it was hard
for me to pull this off but in front of
her because it is the most it's the
biggest breakdown she has she said I she
walked for 90 days and she didn't cry
until the very very very end which I
thought every day she said she only
cried once it was this day but she I
think there's something interesting
about having to deal with your emotions
in front of a child like a lot of people
have said the only reason I got through
the death of my mother's because I had
kids and I didn't have a choice to lay
down and feel sorry for myself and so
this is kind of the first thing where
you see I'm gonna have to figure out a
way to say this stuff in my life and I'm
gonna have to figure out a way to move
on so I think that's it's really kind of
a beautiful moment where she's learning
how she's gonna have to proceed and
something magical is about to happen
here my mother's a singer she's taught
me many songs really what do you like to
hear would you show miss your bright
eyes and sweet smile before you take
with you all of the Sattar Edhi fry
under pathway a while how did this
affect you I mean I can't I can't hardly
even receive it without no idea that's
what that little boy was gonna do I
remember that on the day let's listening
to him because jean-marc saw him first
and I just burst into tears he's such a
soulful little person and he said it
with he's saying it was such heart and
he just I don't know just got to the
heart of me
um and the fact that this really
happened like almost at the end of her
hike and it's there in the book this
little serious voice saying her Red
River Valley and it's just profound you
know what the universe brings into your
life when you're least expecting it and
that can be an incredibly healing woman
well it's my favorite moment in my
favorite movie so thank you so much for
talking about it if you have not seen
wild please do yourself a favor and
check it out and thank you so much for
watching
Fandango frontrunner so Reese - thank
you for joining us today we have made
for you your very own Reese Witherspoon
as Cheryl Strayed
Fandango gift card so take your family
to the movies thank you I love this now
follow me I know you like a selfie here
we go one two three thank you so much
great see you alright